hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play condemned all right so we're
still on our mission to find birds and
pieces of metal
i an't a murderer I think I'm not sure
but I finally get to see miss lady Rosa
oh that's uh that's a no good I hope she
doesn't die she's kind of like the only
link I have into the into the bureau
again they were just munching on a body
here what was going on all right
I don't like this this looks good ah but
it's nothing to me I'm so op dead bird
I'm just the greatest there ever was
were okay
hello oh I don't like this high chair
higher chair
all right I'm okay I'm um I'm so great
they're not even giving me a weapon here
it's really quiet excuse me while I flex
my muscle mid-iron ready to go
hello group basement why do I gotta
fight why would she be in the basement I
never said to I never agreed to meet her
in the basement oh man hi ha Ratz oh oh
lordy Lou okay that was normal
I'm gonna go ahead and agree that that
was perfectly normal this is a good
place to be ha ha I'm so happy that I'm
here anybody wanna mess with me please
hey no get back here
dead bird maybe piece of metal two
favorite things Hojo oh come on
I'm Jackie Chan enough her job no okay
oh hi Thomas over here hey baby
this might not have been a good idea
squatters and addicts have moved in and
they don't like come this way
something to show you I used my security
clearance to do a little checking up on
you
oh yes folder your Supplemental
personnel file okay that taser that
taser
I mean habitated but whatever during
your last physical they found several
abnormalities uh-oh for starters your
bone and muscle densities are off the
chart damn straight ation for being
tough
you also have a hyperactive serotonergic
system in the brain sure God owns I have
no idea and lastly there's a chest x-ray
that's been redacted redacted yeah right
where your esophagus and larynx are
someone's blacked out the x-ray and
added the notation C subjects PR 56 PR
56 is a special addendum to a personnel
record and yours is classified black
that's pretty top level security way
beyond either you or me
our government is awfully interested in
you yeah I know oh who would not need a
me maybe I shouldn't have told you but
there it is oh and I also left something
there on the counter for you
popular modification to the standard
taser haha super taser I like the sound
of that man that's kind of weird I guess
that would explain why Wow
well he's Thomas you okay you look like
you were about to faint your head like
turned on us mobiles over with yeah
scavengers looking for parts to sell are
just maniacs destroying things we have
to find a terminal that isn't damaged
uh-huh
hello huh looks like someone left the
master key in the lock
you started this office I'll take that
one over there that's another computer
that's in working order uh lady okay all
right flavor okay it's good uh haha
closest thing I've gotten to a sword so
far go oh no oh no rose oh ah gosh did I
get you
Hey ah what uh Rosa I'll be right there
milady
hi I'm uh I'm on my way
don't mind me just going crazy here if
I'm in such top physical form hi yeah
that wasn't necessary at all told you we
weren't alone yeah come on
I found a working computer okay yeah if
I'm such a big beefy guy is that why I
can't run that far because my muscles
head bones are just weighing me down
it's a search engine specific to the
library just type in the torturers
that's not garfield should get the
latest info from the local news
including broadcast feeds okay
the torch or or damn it can anything
else go wrong yes I'll have to find the
server room and get the network
Rosa Rosa Rosa Rosa hang it all in there
kind of depressing that officers have to
have those things because otherwise
their employees would be so depressed it
they just want to give up Rosa no okay
hi you don't want to mess with my lady
okay Rosa Rosa are you there what how
would she be about how did she be
abducted she was right there I'm going
insane this guy's not doing so well I
mean he may be a superhuman monster like
me but his mind's a little unstable
unlike mine I am top notch whoa ha oh
I'm taut aah bird I'm super super super
sane what the hell oh what's dis Rosa's
blood
this is Rosa I'm out of the lab at
present but will return shortly in an
emergency please use my authorized
Bureau cell number uh-huh physical
evidence received and stored ooh
who is you Gallardo
ha hey that was my job
hot damn oh all right then
hi hi buddy
come here ride the balls you wanna mess
with me
the answer is no huh
what dumb oh hello you wanna know ride
them all or in the face whatever your
balls look like your face man I think
that's an insult ha ha ha ha where am I
going
hi I see you what's the guy with a fire
axe you that's it hey stop Wow jeez
that guy's have a shotgun and he's just
unlimited really he gets a reload - oh
god not even fair not even fair I on I
got this Wow no ow
balls oh no that statue faces not even
fair it's not fair I Adam kinda
kind of Adam okay wait wait one like oh
I'm dial ah
Oh what's going on mr. man where's the
chopped down to door guy hey what's the
deal what's dealio I collected the ever
dance oh don't tell me it bugged out but
not good that's not good all right
a pretty high security library I have to
say crowbar
damn it I don't have these things and
for some reason they're not coming
through that door damn what's going on
huh oh don't tell me oh don't tell me
you're totally totes mix croats bugged
out aren't you aren't you you are I can
tell oh so sad oh yes it is it is it
frickin is it Frick fracking is it
bugged
well I five professionally developed
game like this would not have that
happen
oh come on Anna Satan forever debate no
no no no oh come on
oh come on go to work go ork wouldn't it
work why won't you work wonk would tell
me how to fix my face well that's
disappointment and a half alright what
I'm going to do his Amish gonna cut this
episode a little short
cuz it's stupid anyway alright if you're
still watching I will take the time to
get back to where I was before I start
recording the next episode so thank you
all so much for watching I'm sorry this
blog Danya thought I failed too much to
die or failed to die I did die it did
not fail to die failed to not survive no
way thanks you all much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I'll see
you in the next part
bye bye